the voice is back and let's talk some
drama by the way blake shelton and gwen
stefani are competing again
and it did not take them long to go from
in love
to at each other's throats
why are you doing this to me what you're
about to break up america's couple
blake and gwen can you know hug and play
and fight and like be
playful and and it's okay oh
great faced off and ultimately gwen
and girl power won that's something
coach kelly is all about
on and off the set i love doing this
show with another female on
in the chairs i'm a girls girl not much
happening backstage this season
just a lot of reflection today would
have been kelly's seventh wedding
anniversary with brandon blackstock
she filed for divorce right before
shooting began on the voice
it is the worst i mean the past few
months have been
horribly sad i do miss giving kelly a
little squeeze that's for sure
we're both blessed that we have our
music to be able to have as an outlet
and if you wonder what kind of influence
blake's had on gwen's music
well check her out last night on fallon
turning her hits
country
meanwhile on dancing peta and vernon
needed some
soothing after getting the boot peta you
look like you're getting a little
emotional i can see it on your face
we love each other very much and this
pro
needed a history lesson we are dancing
to
good vibration
[Music]
who doesn't love mark wahlberg mark well
how does he get into this conversation
because mark wahlberg is marky mark guys
i was also born in 94.
right i was a fetus when marky mark was
seeing these songs
he hasn't even seen boogie nights i
don't even know what that is
so jenna doesn't exactly stand mark
wahlberg but
it looks like caitlyn bristow might be a
little too obsessed
with justin bieber and i want to get
bieber's face tattooed on me
crazy i've always um rooted for
justin i know that sounds weird but i i
don't know if it's the canadian in me
[Music]
and if caitlyn and artem win could
bristow's man jason stop her from
getting a celebratory biebs tat
he knows the importance of sticking true
to a bet but on the other hand
i think he just found that out tonight
when he was watching so yeah i'm like
i don't know what he's going to say
about that a hot tip
just don't get another man's face
tattooed on your body
and we do love a theme so for halloween
next week the stars will dance as famous
movie and tv villains